eigentlich hat online-video fernsehen ja
schon überholt bis 2010 gegen die
tägliche sehdauer im tv immer weiter
nach oben bis zu 223 minuten täglich
fast vier stunden im schnitt seitdem
passiert da nichts mehr und es wächst
nur noch die internetnutzung im letzten
jahr so stark wie nie in füssen mehr
als 80 prozent der bevölkerung über 14
jahren das internet und die technologie
entwickelt sich hier viel schneller als
im klassischen fernsehen live chat
videos im kino auflösung empfangen
nahezu an allen orten apps für
zusatzinformationen video on demand
360° technologisch ist das internet
inzwischen einfach davon gezogen wir
hier wird da wo es vorwärts geht und
was wie wo jetzt möglich dass jetzigen
bis zum 26
herzlich willkommen
die veraltete technologie fernsehen ist
einfach auf dem absteigenden ast in der
jungen zielgruppe von 14 bis 29 jahren
ist die reichweite im internet
inzwischen höher als im fernsehen stets
von 51 zu 46 prozent das heißt mit
online-video werden 51 prozent der
jungen zuschauer täglich erreicht mit
dem fernsehen nur noch 46 prozent das
sind erschreckende zahlen für die
fernsehsender
aber es ist auch nicht verwunderlich
online video funktioniert einfach besser
und dazu gehören natürlich alle
streaming-angebote mediatheken youtube
und so weiter und so fort zum einen kann
online video mit computern smartphones
tablets und smartphones nahezu überall
gesehen werden trotz zahlreicher
versuche hat es bei der tv technik nicht
geklappt sie überall verfügbar zu
machen
dvb-t wurde gerade noch mal neu
gestartet womit die alten geräte
trotzen
aber der empfang bleibt stationär auf
fernseher beschränkt bzw keinem auto
bei hohen geschwindigkeiten nur mit
speziellen empfängern gewährleistet
werden
es ist schon ein bisschen mox probleme
die es bei video on demand nicht gibt's
hier kann zwischen geladen oder
vorgeladen werden sodass sogar unter
schlechten bedingungen videos angeschaut
werden können aber das entscheidende
argument für online video die
technologische entwicklung der neueste
heiße scheiß den gibt es immer zuerst
online und vielleicht erst nach jahren
im tv wie 4k video videos also im kino
auflösung fernsehen fehlanzeige
so weit ist man da noch lange nicht die
idee und zdf wollen die fußball wm 2022
vielleicht im 4k ausstrahlen wow
schon in vier jahren prost oder live
chat die fernsehsender setzen sie auf
twitter
weil wir selbst keine technologie
anbieten können und so weiter und so
fort fernsehen wird einfach von der
technologischen entwicklung abgehängt
neueste sensationelle entwicklung 360°
leisten
der berner jetzt heißt es zum ersten
mal wirklich mittendrin statt nur dabei
dabei ist diese technologie technisch
extrem anspruchsvoll nicht nur erheblich
übertragungsbandbreiten werden hier
benötigt die in dieser qualität und
zuverlässigkeit nur von großen
providern wie der telekom zur verfügung
gestellt werden können auch die kameras
für 360 grad leistung wird höchst
anspruchsvoll
bei dem video des komplett die oso von
nokia zum einsatz ein 40.000 euro gerät
360° training in einer höheren
auflösung zur verfügung stellen kann
die verfügt über achtungs acht
bildsensoren mit einer kino auflösung
von jeweils 2000 2000 big band aus
errechnet sie ein 460 grad signal
dadurch kann er signal 14 k
übertragungswagen gemischt werden
aber auch noch nicht gerade wie sand am
meer gibt also alles absolut das neueste
vom neuen wer sich das mal ansehen will
der kann das übrigens bei den video
days hier aus der lanxess arena in köln
so erleben die telekom bringt nämlich
die video days zu euch nach hause mit
einem 360 grad livestream mit magento
musik tatsächlich könnte die video des
exklusiv live in 360 grad und hd erleben
dann wirklich der absolute hammer das
ganze geht auf der magenta musik 360
webseite oder in der app die video des
live im besten netz der telekom erleben
der link zu diesem außergewöhnlichen
technologisch wie auch schon erwähnte
es hier einfach draufklicken und ihr
seid dabei und das ist wirklich so das
ist eben auch auf dem smartphone tablet
und so weiter der absolute wahnsinn als
wäre man wirklich mittendrin und
schreibt mir unter das video wie ihr
diesen live stream erlebt habe ich freue
mich auf jeden fall auf euch bei dieser
show die dieses jahr nochmal
sensationeller wird als je also
ansonsten bestand bleibt dran